willkommen zur heutigen sitzung in der
wir uns nochmal mit diesen netten herrn
hier beschäftigen werden und zwar in der
heutigen sitzung werden wir zwei formen
von kausalität behandeln nämlich einmal
wie wir es schon letzten mal gemacht
hatten die kausalität der natur
es ist natur der termin ismus und wir
werden auch noch eine weitere
kausalitäten behandelt die kant nennt
die kausalität durch freiheit oder
kausalität aus freiheit kann äußert sich
darüber verschiedene weise
man könnte sagen das ist die natur
kausalität und das ist die freiheits
kausalität oder auch vernunft kausalität
also es gibt ja immer diese opposition
natur versus vernunft oder natur versus
freiheit und wir wollen eben heute nicht
nur die natur kausalität behandeln
von der kann zeigt dass es sie gibt
sondern wir wollen auch noch die
freiheits kausalität behandeln von der
kant ebenfalls sagt dass es sie gibt und
ursprünglich hatte ich vor dass wir hier
auf die kritik der praktischen vernunft
dazu eingehen aber es ist gar nicht
nötig weil kann über die kausalität aus
freiheit bereits etwas in der kritik der
reinen vernunft ebenfalls gesagt hat in
der auflösung der dritten antinori wo es
eben darum geht wie freiheit und
determinismus kompatibel sind also für
diejenigen unter ihnen die sich noch
mehr mit der kausalität aus freiheit
beschäftigen wollen für diejenigen sei
ein blick in die kritik der praktischen
15 empfohlen aber es ist gar nicht so
notwendig wie ich ursprünglich dachte
okay jetzt gehen wir noch mal hier auf
die zweite analogie die erfahrung kurz
ein die ich mit ihnen zusammen der
letzten sitzung diskutiert hatte wir
hatten der letzten sitzung sehr viel
drauf geachtet wie sich das
qualitätsverständnis verkannt von
demjenigen davy teams abgrenzt rasieren
sich jung sagte kausalität diese
notwendige zeit des übergangs von
ursache zur wirkung dieser dieses
zwingende was daran liegt dass eine
ursache ihrer wirkung hervorbringen muss
das sagte jung liegt in uns dieser zwang
wir
können nicht anders als wenn wir ein
ereignis als eine ursache zu erkennen
glauben oder kategorisieren oder
qualifizieren dann nach hause zu gehen
dass jetzt auch eine entsprechende
wirkung folgen muss wir haben seine
erwartungshaltung erwartungshaltung
disposition und das nennt jedenfalls
kantig junge den glaube das ist so als
eine psychologische einstellung die
durch gewöhnung also konditioniert ist
könnte man schon fast eine
konditionierung in der gewissen weise
und wir können sagen natürlich täuschen
und kant geht nicht so weit zu sagen
dass das eine psychologische sache ist
sagt das ist eine durch und durch
nationale angelegenheit wenn wir von
kausalität sprechen es geht um die
objektivität von kausalität und nicht um
die subjektivität könnte uns erkannt
wird diese objektivität der kausalität
durch bezug auf eine subjektivität
theorie begründen
das ist eine transzendentale
philosophieren dann hatte ich so ein
bisschen das ganze veranschaulicht ich
hatte dann gesagt das sind alles
rahmungen also wir haben bekannt gibt es
natürlich auch sinneseindrücke das gibt
es auch sind es material also man könnte
sagen bekannt gibt es vorn und materie
ganz ähnlich wie bei aristoteles die
materie ist bei kant etwas was wir in
nur ganz wenigen fällen selbst leisten
können also wirklich gehalt gehalt
bekommen wir nach kant immer von außen
also das ist dieses element bei der
video was nach als perzeption zeichen
könnte der sinneseindruck zum beispiel
rot wahrnehmen
roth wahrnehmung oder das gefühl von
kälte oder solches basalen
sinneseindrücke die stammen auch nach
kant von außen oder jedenfalls die
stammen nicht von uns die müssen uns wie
kann einer anderen stelle sagt gegeben
sein da gewissen weise
hier kann man natürlich dann wieder
fragen ist es nicht ein mythos des
gegebenen muss nicht um damit etwas
gegeben es ist auch schon noch mehr
gegeben sein was im vermeintliche geben
und gar nicht
ist zum beispiel das etwas als etwas
schreiben kann
aber kann sagt jedenfalls diese seite
diese passivität also dass etwas auf uns
einströmen muss sei es jetzt eine rot
eindruck sei es ein geruch oder sowas
dass das muss jedenfalls vonhausen
gegeben sein das soll jetzt mal sonnig
symbolisieren das sind so basale sind es
eindrücke so weit geht damit der video
akkorden aber er geht nicht damit der
chor zu sagen dass wir über diese
perzeption diese basalen sind es
eindrücke dass wir darüber so was wie
das ich erklären können unter raum oder
zeit oder auch substanzen konnte david
hume ja auch gar nicht hat er mit diesen
ganzen problem dingen probleme wie mit
dem ich mit der substanz mit raum und
zeit sondern kann zeigt das was
jugendliche gefunden hat was er darin
sucht denn diese nixon
das konnte er darin gar nicht entdecken
weil es darin gar nicht liegt als
nämlich außerhalb der xe liegt wie ich
hatte das als solche rahmungen
beschrieben zb dieser erste rahmen
könnte jetzt zum beispiel die causa
kausale geordnet hat diese dieser
ereignisse bedeuten das wäre dieser
rahmen die kategorie der kausalität die
liegt nicht in den dingen drin sondern
die wird von uns als trans zentralen
subjekten wie kann sagt mit
hineingebracht
und dann könnte man sagen gut über die
kausalität legen wir noch eine form ist
jetzt natürlich ganz allgemein hat
gesagt dafür einfach gesagt und zwar
könnten wir jetzt was können wir noch
für eine form
darüber lägen zum beispiel die der
substanz wir haben also jetzt plötzlich
substanzen also dinge die miteinander in
kausalem verhältnissen stehen und können
wir wieder müssen noch eine rahmung
darum machen nämlich noch den raum die
dinge befinden sich ja im raum
die sind ja lokalisierbar die dinge die
im chaos einer wechselwirkung stehen
und natürlich müssen die auch noch in
der zeit sein
das ist dann die nächste rahmung das ist
dann der innere sinn ja aber es ist in
der zeit
wir beziehen die sinneseindrücke durch
die vorstellung aufeinander dass man
kann dann diese ab herceptin das wird
das äußere wird also nach kant durch die
vorstellung durch die verarbeitung durch
unseren verstand so etwas inneren und
insofern etwas etwas inneren wird das
hier mit diesen ganzen formen versorgt
wird gehört es dann natürlich der zeit
zum inneren sinn also so viele
erfahrungen kommen darum und jung
versuchte diese ganzen bedeutung also
hier wie gesagt zeit zeitraum sobald es
nicht alle substanz kausalität ganz jung
versuchte diese ganzen dinge oder
reformen in diesen eindrücken zu finden
konnte es aber nicht machen wir können
zeit sagt jedenfalls kann und das ist
ein plausibles argument nicht dadurch
erklären dass wir relationen von
sinneseindrücken analysieren wir müssen
um sie in ihrer abfolge zu analysieren
immer schon die zeit voraussetzen
leibnitz hingegen sagte was anderes den
haben wir jetzt hier nicht behandelt
aber nicht sagt nein
um zeit erklären zu wollen oder können
müssen wir erst relationen betrachten
und die relationen sind nicht zeitlich
das ein riesen riesending ob man das so
erklären habe jedenfalls kann sagt wir
können es nicht auf basis der bloßen
perzeption sein wir brauchen die reine
anfangs form derzeit um eben zeitliche
dingen ihrer wechsel in ihrer abfolge
erkennen zu können und auch überhaupt in
kausalem verhältnissen bestimmen zu
können okay jetzt hatte ich diese ganzen
leitfragen hier die habe ich jetzt immer
auch schon an die wand geworfen eine
neue frage ist hinzugekommen nämlich die
letzte und zwar inwiefern ist ist denkt
möglich kausalität der natur und
qualität aus freiheit miteinander zu
vereinbaren
das ist eine neue frage die heute mit
anzukommen kant geht nämlich davon aus
dass wir es mit zwei arten von
kausalität zu tun haben mit natur
kausalität und das ist hier so was wie
akteurs kausalität also wir sind nicht
nur natürlich gewesen wir sind nicht nur
bestimmt durch das naturgesetz dass zu
erklären ist schon schwer genug
wie es dazu kommen kann sondern wir sind
obwohl wir vom naturgesetz vollständig
die terminiert sind zugleich auch noch
frei in unserem handeln das heißt wir
können selbst kausalketten aussenden die
vor uns keine ursache hatten
also es ist so was wie ein unbewegter
bewege an erste ursachen hier sind wir
und hier geht es dann los mit den ganzen
körper erkennen
aber hier davor war nichts und so
versteht kann die causa aus freiheit
bekommen da noch darauf zu sprechen ob
sich so was lässt sich natürlich denken
aber lässt sich so was auch konsequent
mit einer vollständigen determiniert
hyde der natur vereint
das ist die spannende frage wir werden
da ein bisschen noch draufkommen
der fokus soll aber letztendlich auf
dieser zweiten analogie der erfahrung
liegen und kann sagt hier eben es ist
die der grundsatz der zeit folge nach
dem gesetz der kausalität und das ist
dieser grundsatz alle veränderung
geschehen nachdem gesetze der
verknüpfung der ursache und wirkung als
alles was ich überhaupt nur verändern
kann als ein vollständiger determinismus
was hat es den vollen vorteil wenn wir
diesen grundsatz jetzt belegen können
oder wenn wir ihnen plausibilität ihren
können was ist damit gewonnen wenn wir
sagen können alles was sich verändert
alles was da geschieht geschieht nach
diesem gesetz das hat es von vorteil
warum ist es kann so wichtig wie kann so
wichtig dieses diesen grundsatz
aufzustellen und zu verteidigen
genau er denkt das ganze auch von einem
sehr praktischen standpunkt aus nämlich
als physiker er hat ja auch da eine
gewisse ausbildung gehabt also wir
können eben dann forschen in der natur
wenn wir diesen grundsatz an dem kombi
wissen es muss für alles was es gibt
muss es eine ursache geben wir können
allem auf den grund gehen und es nicht
so wie es heute in der quantenphysik der
fall ist dass wir eben von man die dinge
dann ganz kleinen dingen eben keine
ursachen mehr angeben können so nur mit
statistischen verteilung rechnen können
oder wenn wir eben den atom zerfall
angeben wollen erklären wollen
einkommensstatistik angehen das
statistische verteilung aber wir können
nicht genau sagen zu welchem zeitpunkt
jetzt was der fall sein wird da wird es
dann also ganz schwierig bei diesen
kleinen dimensionen also das hatte
kannte natürlich nicht wissen können
aber so generell denke ich beschreibt er
unser denken sehr richtig trotz dieser
neueren erkenntnisse wir können nicht
anders aber das hat er auch eigentlich
individuum gesagt wir können nicht
anders als so zu denken als ob alles was
da geschieht eine ursache hat kant geht
so weit zu sagen es hat auch natürlich
alles was dann geschieht und die ursache
das ist natürlich noch ein stärkerer
stärkeres argument noch ein oder stärke
these als die von der video der wird
jung bleibt auf seinen psychologischen
ebene
sie kennen den spruch ich habe ich habe
ihn schon mal auch angekündigt am anfang
des semesters von friedrich nietzsche
das ist so dem sina sagte alle der
mensch der verkraftet alles der erträgt
alles wenn man ihnen nur den grund dafür
angeben
es liegt einfach wir sind dadurch
befriedigt oder auch erleichtert wenn
wir nicht mehr diese ungewissheit haben
warum das jetzt der fall wir wollen
immer auch die warum frage stellen
man kann sagen der mensch ist das wesen
das warum fragt das wohl der menschen
dieser sache auf den grund gehen und
wenn über nacht leben warum fragt dann
ich kann das einmal so natürliche
ursache sein
aber natürlich kann auch die warum frage
dann sich nach der zurechenbarkeit
richten also warum hast du das getan was
waren deine gründe geht es um gründe und
nicht mehr um
ursachen das ist immer so ein bisschen
ich schreibe jetzt mal hierhin also hier
geht es um gründe oder den grund jetzt
investieren zu wollen
hierzu ursachen wenn jemand etwas getan
hat dann würde man nicht sagen
also wenn er jetzt aus freiheit getan
hat die person würde mir nicht sagen
dass die person ist als ursache getan
hat die person war nicht die ursache
würde man nicht zu erhalten würde sagen
das unwetter war die ursache für den
schaden entstand ist man würde sagen die
person hatte gründe der grund war der
die person wollte das und das tun und
deswegen hat sie es getan man spricht
nicht von ursachen
man spricht vielleicht von verursachen
eine person verursacht ein schaden
aber wenn man dann von verursachen
spricht dann wird es gleich wieder so
als sei es ebenso nicht willentlich
geburt gewesen es ist halt passiert ist
jemand halt zu schnell gefahren und dann
verursachte diese person mit diesem
wagen diesen schaden dann würde aber
nicht sagen was war der grund
gut man könnte vielleicht damit geht
wenn man genauer hinschaut sagen der
grund war alkohol am steuer
der grund dafür war der person hatte
irgendwie schlechte laune und hat
deswegen ein bisschen zu viel getrunken
worden
okay dann ist man wieder auf den gründen
aber jedenfalls ist diese unterscheidung
ist wichtig ursachen und gründe
die wissenschaftler gehen auch im wege
vor der geburt bereich muss dazu noch
mal
wieso vor sind
ja da spielen dann gründe eine rolle
genau ich glaube es geht um hiv hiv
resistenten das ist das motiv das motiv
ist dann man will da menschen züchten
die nicht mehr an hiv anfällig sind
offensichtlich und dann spielt man das
ist lustig ein guter punkt was sie da
drin weil dann greift der mensch selbst
ein in den naturkreislauf und wird
selbst auch irgendwas andere ursachen
als gründe bestimmen dann die ursachen
in der natur also der natürliche lauf
sich naturgesetzlich entwickelt der wird
sondern durch gründe beeinflusst und das
sieht man schon dass wir aus freiheit in
die natur eingreifen können letztendlich
und das ist die spannende frage wie
diese beiden sachen naturkost und
freiheitskampf miteinander zusammen
denkbar sind okay und jetzt haben wieder
ruhig noch mal ganz kurz zum letzten mal
ein bisschen weiter alte das ist
vielleicht mit eines der zentralen
zitate hier in diesem kontext der
begriff aber sagt jetzt hier kannte er
eine notwendigkeit der synthetischen
einheit bei sich führt und kann nur ein
reiner verstandes begriff sein denn
nicht in der wahrnehmung und das ist
jetzt gegen david hume gerichte und das
ist hier der begriff des verhältnisses
der ursache und wirkung aber von die
erstere die letzte in der zeit als die
folge und nicht als etwas bösiger
einbildung vorher gehen oder gar überall
nicht wahrgenommen sein könnte bestimmt
alter ist nur dadurch dass wir die folge
der erscheinungen alle veränderungen dem
gesetze der kausalität unterwerfen
selbsterfahrung das ist empirische
erkenntnis von denselben möglich mithin
sind sie selbst als gegenstände die
erfahrung nur nach eben den gesetzen
möglich also
was ab geht's nochmal kant mit blick auf
jugend war es jetzt erfahrung angelangt
also jugend sagte wir können und wir
müssen versuchen die kausalität relation
und die das kausale wirken aus der
erfahrung zu gewinnen
wie sieht es jetzt kannte also die
perspektive bei jugend ursache wirkung
kam sanitätsstation aus der erfahrung
muss erkannt werden können
[Musik]
in den armen diese diese
umgeben ist
das heißt anderes können wir keine
erfahrung
frauen machen
das ist richtig aber wenn sie es noch
ein bisschen mehr zuspitzen als die
frage nach dem verhältnis von erfahrung
und kausalität regierung versucht die
kausalität relation das kausale
verfahren aus der erfahrung aus diesen
x10 hier dessen sinneseindrücke zu
gewinnen konnte er nicht was sagt jetzt
kann hier in diesem part
es ist im letzten satz diesem zitat
diese also also ist nur dadurch
diesmal nicht aus dem verfahren ja ja
genau und jetzt könnte man so ein
bisschen anders formulieren also wir
gewinnen die kausalität relation nicht
aus der erfahrung sondern wir gewinnen
die erfahrung erst aus der kanzlei lietz
relation zu lesen also sagt es nur
dadurch dass wir das gesetz der
kausalität annehmen dürfen oder
gesichert besitzen
dadurch ist erst erfahrungen möglich
jung ging davon aus dass wir erfahrung
frei haus haben letztendlich das wie
einfach diese extreme hier habe er ging
davon aus dass die schon geordnet sind
auch eine gewisse weise und kann würde
sagen erfahrung könne überhaupt erst
machen wenn wir diesen rahmen der
kausalität hier schon voraussetzen
also wir sollten sich die kausalität aus
der erfahrung glauben zu gewinnen so nur
wenn wir qualität schon voraussetzen
das ist dann notwendig gewissermaßen
förderung können überhaupt erfahrung
machen
er hatte vielleicht liegt ja jetzt auch
ein anderer erfahrungs begriff zugrunde
das kann natürlich sein aber als
erfahrung ist immer schon etwas was
voraussetzungen besitzt erfahrung
bekommen wir nicht frei haus das ist
wieder der mythos des gegebenen da kommt
irgendwie was strömt auf uns zu und
dadurch machen wir erfahren ja dann sagt
kann aber das was auf uns einströmen
muss doch schon irgendwie geordnet sein
und jung hatte gezeigt dass diese aktien
hier eigentlich gar keine ordnung
aufweist
also wenn die ordnung im spiel ist dann
müssen die muss die ordnung von woanders
kommen die ordnung muss schon
vorausgesetzt bisschen diese ganzen
rahmen hier also nur ein paar warnungen
kausalität substanz raumzeit gibt noch
viel mehr wechselwirkung akzidenz
substanz aktie das haben wir schon das
sind die ganzen verstandes kategorien
von den kanton spricht
einheit vielheit ist zum beispiel dass
auch wenn es um die identität von dinge
geht
das ist alles kategorien die wir aus der
erfahrung selbst nicht gewinnen können
also hier sagt kant also die
notwendigkeit der synthetischen einheit
das ist also der übergang von ursache
wirkung ist eine synthetische einheits
erkannt kann nur ein reiner verstandes
begriff sein
also notwendigkeit bekommen nicht aus
der erfahrung wie jung sie dachten wir
bekommen notwendigkeit nur durch
rahmungen in den in der in den überhaupt
erfahrung stattfinden kann ist glauben
ganz wichtiges getan und jetzt hat er
hier dieses schiff und jetzt gibt jetzt
kann man mal ein bisschen weiter also
sagt ich sehe zum beispiel ein schiff
den strom hin abtreiben meine
wahrnehmung seiner stelle unterhalb
folgt auf die wahrnehmung der stelle des
helden oberhalb dem laufe des flusses
und es ist unmöglich dass in der
prävention dieser erscheinung das schiff
zuerst unterhalb nachher aber oberhalb
des stromes wahrgenommen werden sollte
die ordnung in der folge der bahn in der
prävention ist hier also bestimmt und an
diese liebe ist die letztere gebunden
in dem vorigen beispiele von einem hause
ein aus was stillstand soll ein
fixiertem aus den erdbebenregionen ist
ist natürlich etwas anders konnten meine
wahrnehmung in der prävention von der
spitze des selben anfang und beim boden
endingen aber auch von unten anfangen
und oben endingen im gleichen rechts
oder links das mannigfaltige der
empirischen anschauen präsentieren
in der reihe diese wahrnehmung war also
keine bestimmte ordnung welche es
notwendig machte wenn ich in der
prävention wann muss es natürlich heißen
aber kann zeigt hier dass es eben diese
alten ausgabe die originalausgabe wann
ich in der prävention anfangen müsste um
das mannigfaltige empirisch zu verbinden
diese regel aber ist bei der warnung von
dem was geschieht jederzeit anzutreffen
und sie macht die ortung der einander
folgenden wahrnehmung
in der abgrenzung diese erscheinung
notwendig und sie haben zuletzt ganz
richtig hingewiesen auf dieses wort
notwendig also es geht um diese
verbindlichkeit von der kant auch schon
hier im vorherigen zitat sprach hier von
der notwendigkeit des synthetischen
einhalten sowas hat setzt damit auch sie
erbringt das beispiel eines stromes und
eines hauses
was würde der unterschied
bei der prävention
m
diese bewegten des faustschlages und
bedingen sich verändern ist
muss einiges
daraus macht er das immer die
tatsächlich jemals
seine freundin ist eine
großveranstaltung
genau also bei kausalen veränderungen
ist die wahrnehmung festgelegt wir
können nicht ein schiff erst im
rückwärtslaufen sehen gegen natürlich
schon jetzt im rückwärts antrieb dann
fährt in den fluss hoch aber
normalerweise also nehmen wir ein schiff
was sind krumm herunter treibt erst oben
war und dann wie es unter und beim haus
ist eben anders ein haus ist jetzt nicht
kausal bewegt kausal verändert das steht
fest ist seit dem gewinn einer
erdbebenregion aber bei still stehenden
objekten das ist ja sehr klar können wir
von oben nach unten ab rentieren die
wahrnehmung ist dadurch nicht in eine
bestimmte richtung gelenkt ich habe das
nicht mit kausal erfahrung zu tun und
die unveränderte objekte nehmen wir
nicht kausal bar
genau
nach
schön war dass wenn es anders wäre
sie war das kann ich verstehen also zu
sagen es ist wichtig das macht einen
unterschied wie man was und das ist ein
haus nämlich egal
ist das nicht ein bisschen zirkulären
mutet ist an also ein bisschen gut genau
und dann müsste man eben sagen in diesem
fall wäre es wäre dann die kausale
richtung eben eine an trennen aber ich
denke wir können da setzt man nur so
betrachten im sinne dessen das kant
einfach darauf zu sprechen kommt wie wir
kausale erfahrung machen bei der
kausalen erfahrung hängt es nicht von
uns ab wie die prävention ist das hatten
sie gesagt beim haus hängt von uns ab
volker nichts vor und nach oben
betrachten bei einer kausalen ordnung
nicht ob das schiff beispiel jetzt
genauer zu trifft mit diesem oben unten
das ist ein anderer punkt da würde ich
ihnen erst mal zustimmen aber dass
natürlich die schiff wahrnehmung nicht
von uns abhängt so viel kann man ihn ja
denke schon zugestimmt
es beginnt irgendwie irgendwo und dann
muss ich ihm folgen die aktion folgt
diesem gesetz der ursache und wirkung
und das ist bei einem haus nicht so
erfahrungen und ein begriff die bereits
wissen dass die bearbeitung von
erfahrung erfolg so was wie großes fest
steht dass heißt
da sind immer zwei faktoren durch da
wird gleichberechtigt sind
einmal die veränderung des standortes
erster und gewissen zeit
dieser vorgang luft und der läuft obwohl
das nicht diese erfahrung realistische
genommen bestätigt und besser erklärt er
gebracht erfahren und diese ist eben vom
vom thema an sich die sozialistischen
geschrieben
das ist tatsächlich nicht so wichtig
verkannt weil das ding an sich was auch
immer das jetzt ist das würde uns nie in
raum und zeit gegeben sein können und
auch nicht im chaos ali t
die ganzen kategorien die ganzen
rahmungen die treffen nicht auf das ding
an sich zu also man könnte sagen das
ding an sich ist vielleicht das und
jetzt muss ich wieder aufpassen was ich
sage
von dem diese entstammen wobei wir nicht
so rede wie von dem die aktien stammen
würde ich wieder so was wie kausalität
einführen und vielleicht sagen das ding
an sich ist die ursache dieser aktien
deswegen würde ich es anders formulieren
würde sagen sagen vielleicht die
sexszenen dingern sich fundiert weil
fundierung ist logische metaphysische
relation die jetzt nicht bekannt eine
kategorie darstellt ist es keine rahmen
ich müsste von den dingern sich was
vielleicht der grund dieser aktien ist
so sprechen dass dieses verhältnis von
dingen sind sich und häkchen keine
dieser rahmungen betrifft weil diese
rahmung nur mögliche gegenstände
erfahrung betreffen das ding an sich in
sky möglicher gegenstand erfahren und
das war ein vorwurf den jacobi friedrich
heinrich jacobi ein zeitgenosse ganz
gegen kann vorgebracht hatte er sagte
kant du sagst das ding an sich ist die
ursache dieser x10 aber ursächlichkeit
betrifft nur mögliche gegenstände
erfahrung
das heißt du gehst jetzt dahinter
sozusagen hinter dixon zurück und hier
ist dann das ding und sich aber diese
causa relation die ich jetzt hier feilen
gestrichelten teil andeutet die findet
statt außerhalb dieser möglichen rahmen
also das ist etwas was außerhalb dem
rahmen stattfinden das war der vorwurf
von jakobiner wenn noch ein kurzer punkt
dazu sie haben recht als es ist ein
realistischer aspekt aber der
realistische aspekt ist eben tatsächlich
fundiert oder begründet in diesen rahmen
die wiederum vom subjekt com
aber kann versucht eben zu sagen dass
diese rahmung notwendig sind also dass
das dass sie nicht willkürlich sind auch
uns nicht zur verfügung stimmung
so nicht es ist nicht korea tief gedacht
es ist eben nach kant nicht kreativ
gedacht sondern es ist konstitutiv
gedacht also diese rahmen die bringen
den gegenstand erst hervor als es nicht
so dass da etwas ist und ich entspreche
diesem gegenstand durch meine kognitiven
oder ich repräsentiere ihn sagen ich
schaffe ich erzeuge ich konstruiere ihn
erst durch diese ganzen kategorien und
das ist eben das schwierige senken
inwiefern diese ganzen rahmungen hier
inwiefern die objektive geltung
ermöglichen und nicht irgendwie
subjektivität individualität kann denkt
diese ganzen rahmen transzendentale
transplantat bedeutet bezogen auf das
subjekt aber nicht bezogen auf das
objekt als ein individuum ist als dieses
trans zentrales objekt was die bedingung
der möglichkeit von erfahrung ist als er
denkt diese ganzen sachen sehr stark
logisch logisch subjektiv jetzt hatten
sie sich mit er ist der konditor wänden
ja
ein beispiel im schiffweiler
nachschieben
objekt der betrachtung kann sondern sein
leben
das bedeutet es wäre ja jeder andere
gewesen war
aber dadurch dass ich diese regelung
nach boden liegt
wenn es anders wäre wäre das leben mit
diesem argument der rhein zeitung
und diese diese erfahrung wäre eben
nicht abhängig von uns also ich könnte
nicht sagen ich möchte jetzt in das
schiff von oben nach unten fließt
er möchte ich indem ich es anders
wahrnehmen indem ich jetzt nach oben
schauen dass das schiff jetzt plötzlich
wieder oben ist und das geht beim haus
ebenso wurde bei teilen des hauses sag
jetzt mal im haus geht es natürlich auch
nicht ich kann nicht wenn das haus da
steht und ich schaue dahin wollen dass
das haus jetzt dort ist wo ich jetzt
hinschaue das ist klar aber ich kann
jedenfalls bestimmte teile des hauses
fokussieren ich kann nach unten schauen
das obere fans des oberen fenstern und
alles bleibt dann bleibt dann da jetzt
haben sich zwei gemeldet erst rechts und
links
also sind das zentrale anschauungs form
und genau genommen
es ist es ist klar räumliches kann ich
nur dann erfahren wenn ich diese x10
habe wenn ich diese sinneswahrnehmungen
habe die reine anschauungs form des
raumes derzeit die nehme ich selbst
nicht wahr
die kann ich ja ich kann ich den reinen
raum wahrnehmen das geht nicht kann
immer nur räumliches wahrnehmen und
damit ich räumliches wahrnehmen kann
müssen wir solche gags hingegeben seien
solche basalen sinneseindrücke und von
den seit eben kann zu kam er ihn lesen
die stammen von dem ding an sich die
gehen da irgendwie zurück ich mache mal
dass wir uns besser sieht von da also
sagen diese x10 die sind zurückzuführen
auf ein großes x2 und von dem werden die
irgendwie verursacht darf man nicht
sagen weil die raben die rahmung der
übersichtlichkeit nur hier diesen rahmen
möglicher erfahrung ist und das ist ja
kein gegenstand erfahren also das ist so
das ist ein riesen eine riesen debatte
wie man das ding an sich überhaupt
verstehen soll
die frage ist ja schon die ob kann von
einem ding an sich spricht als ob er und
redet oder ob er nur wie gerold preis
ein kann fortschritt gezeigt hat oder
glaubt hatte zu zeigen von dem ding an
sich selbst betrachtet spricht wäre es
nämlich eine reine apps technologische
angelegenheit dann wäre es so als ob das
system an sich ist dann wären es wäre es
eine schwächere thesen also man kann ihn
stark lesen und schwach lesen man kann
auch das ding jetzt an sich als etwas
logisches verstehen das ist mir
sympathisch und dass man sagt es ist
irgendwie die fundierung dieser fixen
dieses ihren verfügbaren moment was bei
erfahrung einfach immer eine rolle
spielt der grund dafür dass wir eben
nicht willentlich wollen wir steuern
können wohin das schiff jetzt fährt das
ganze könnte darin irgendwie fundiert
sein
hier muss man ganz aufpassen weil man
darf hier dann über das ding an sich
nicht mehr kausal reden im sinne einer
kapsel relation man darf nicht mehr
reden als substanz diese ganzen
kategorie substanz raumzeit qualität
sind nicht anwendbar auf das ding sich
das heißt man kann vom dingern sich gar
nicht sinnvoll eigentlich reden weil wir
die kategorien dafür nicht anwenden
können deswegen bleibt eigentlich nur
noch das ding an sich als etwas
logisches anzusehen
im logischen raum gilt weder zeit noch
kausalität noch raum noch substanz wenn
sie mathematik betreiben
bewegen sie sich in der reihe also die
ideellen mathematik nicht jetzt in der
der psychologischen mathematik wenn es
wenn es um mathematische verhältnisse
und logischer verhältnisse ab leitungs
verhältnis reduktion usw
bewegen sie sich in der zeit wenn man
könnte sagen es gibt vielleicht eine
logische zeit aber jedenfalls nicht in
diesen anschauungs formen ist ja ich
würde dafür plädieren das ding an sich
im sinn einer logischen entität zu
verstehen die nicht diesen kategorien
unter deck jahr hatten sie sich gewählt
als ein riesending wie man das ding an
sich versteht könnte man auch ein
eigenes seminar dazu machen
es ist glaube ich zu speziell diese
frage stellen
jetzt hatten sie sich
da müsste man eben aufpassen
[Musik]
aber sie müssten dann eben auch noch
sagen dass dieses ding an sich nicht
kausal strukturiert sein dürfte sie
dürfen über diese dinge sich der blick
von javi aber da muss man dann schon
also aber das mit dem sehen ist jetzt
ein bisschen zu allgemein also es geht
also sehen erkennen müsste man sagen
also wir müssen sagen erkennen und kant
würde sagen wir können es eben
prinzipiell nicht erkennen weil erkennen
bedeutet diese ganzen rahmungen um die
erfahrung rom zu tun
genauso kann man es verstehen also dass
praktisch ein mögliches objekt
vielleicht das aber eigentlich kein
objekte erfahrung sein kann weil
erfahrung zu haben bedeutet diese ganzen
rahmungen um die iks hin um zu haben
viele sagen eben die das ist der grund
dieser sinneseindrücke dass wir
überhaupt irgendwelche sinneseindrücke
machen können dass uns etwas als
anschauung gegeben ist dieses momentes
passiv wir bringen ja hier ganz viel
aktivität mit kausalität substantially
traumzeit das sind alles dinge der
spontanität zuerkannt wir bringen die
mit rein
wir legen das ganze wir stülpen das
gewissermaßen über die erfahrung über
und es gibt neben noch einen moment der
passivität etwas was uns gegeben wird
das sind diese kann man sich fragen
woher kommen die six
naja gut die frage woher sie kommen ist
schon problematisch weil wir dann
natürlich nach den pauschalen ursprung
fragen nach der ursache
das dürfen wir aber nicht weil wir dann
aus dem rahmen rausfallen ansehen ist es
ganz schwierig darüber zu reden ich
finde diesen dieses angebot nicht nicht
schlecht sagt der blick vermöbelt wo nur
davon darf man eben nichts sagen dass
das was von nirgendwo aus betrachtet
würde kausal strukturiert wird müsste
sagen es darf nicht seitlich sein muss
nicht zeitlich sei nicht räumlich nicht
substanziell nicht nicht nicht kausal
sogar nicht mal eine einheit dürfte es
aufweisen diese ganzen logischen form
dürfen wir nicht arbeiten
nein das nach kant dürfte es so nicht
sein also nach kann streng genommen
nicht weil er das ganze diese ganzen
kategorien hier nur auf mögliche
gegenstand erfahrung bezieht natürlich
kann mir zwar gekannt zeigst du uns auch
dass es nicht noch auf was anderes
angewendet werden könnte aber der
anspruch von ihm ist der dass es nur auf
erfahrung angewendet werden kann
es kann so argumentiert kann jedenfalls
nicht auf ein mögliches dingern sich
angewendet werden
die von allen vernünftigen wesen von
allen endlichen vernünftig gewesen also
auch ob man jetzt facettenaugen hat oder
nicht es würde verkannt hier keine rolle
spielen wenn man ihnen streng ließ weil
er nicht von menschen spricht kann
trifft vertritt keine betreibt keine
anthropologie er spricht auch in der
kritik der reinen vernunft so gut wie
nie vor mensch entspricht
es sind also als kann spricht von
endlichen wesen des könnten auch
außerirdisches seien anerkannt hat gute
gründe nicht von menschen zu sprechen
wenn wir dann sofort in so ein
relativismus reinkommen und
anthropologie ist verkannt etwas was
empirisch ist kann möchte trans zentral
philosophische argumentieren dass heißt
er möchte
logisch argumentieren und nicht so sehr
von unserer kontingenten zufälligen
ausstattungen er möchte verbindliche
erkenntnisse formulieren und die würden
auch zum beispiel für endlich aus
gewesen gelten auch die müssten so ihre
erkenntnis fähigkeit strukturiert sein
und das ist auch das große verdienst der
kantischen theorie dass er anders als
david hume nicht mehr eine anthropologin
der psychologie betreibt
willkommen
es gibt natürlich zwei arten von
gesetzen es gibt es moral gesetz und es
gibt es kausalität gesetz also dass die
kausalität aus freiheit die gründe die
kommt genau und das qualitäts gesetz
auch für alle endlichen wesen als auch
die können nur erkennen nach qualitäts
gesetzen das ist im text nicht drin das
ist natürlich ein größeres ding ich
meine das ist
wir können natürlich unmöglich in zwei
sitzungen die ganze theorie erkennen das
muss man eben sich gesagt gesagt
bekommen oder man muss es eben schon
wissen oder noch noch noch lernen aber
also kant betreibt hier definitiv keine
anthropologie und das ist ganz wichtig
um eben von david hume abzugrenzen
zum beispiel ein absolutes wesen ein
reines vernunft wesen würde auch nicht
so erkennen wie wir
man kann sich zum beispiel fragen ob ein
rein ist und das ist spekulativ wie sich
eine ein reines fünf gewesen ein
unendliches gewesen wie sich das zum
ding an sich verhalten würde das ist
eine riesen frage gibt es verschiedene
thesen und dann aber erkannt hat einen
ganz engen fokus auf endliche empirisch
vernünftige wie es also wissen die eben
selbst zb immer auf erfahrung angewiesen
sind kann spricht auch von einem
intellektuell archetypus das ist die
vernunft eines absoluten wesens welches
zum beispiel dann gerade das tun könnte
was wir jetzt endlich gewesen
ausgeschlossen haben nämlich das denn
ein schiff unter treibt das man nach
oben schaut oder eine zuschrift
plötzlich oben obwohl es eigentlich
unten selbst wie wir es beim haus machen
können ansetzen so was ist nach kant
möglichkeit eines lektors articus der
intellektuelle typus der erzeugt selbst
doch diese x10 hier drin
der erzeugt
alles der braucht nichts gegeben das ist
ein intellektueller aber sowas sagt kann
geht für etliche wesentlich als erwägt
schon die möglichkeit eines absoluten
verstandes ok sehen anhänger also ganz
viele fragen mit zusammen und wir lesen
jetzt noch mal das nächste start einer
solchen regel also muss in dem was
vorübergeht vor einer begebenheit vorher
geht die bedingung zu einer regel liegen
nach welche jederzeit und
notwendigerweise diese begebenheit folgt
umgekehrt aber kann ich nicht von der
begebenheit zurückgehen und das wenige
bestimmen durch prävention was vorher
geht denn von dem folgenden zeitpunkt
geht keine erscheinung zu dem vorigen
zurück bezieht sich doch auch
irgendeinen vorigen von einer gegebenen
zeit ist dagegen der fortgang auf die
bestimmte folgende notwendig daher weil
es doch etwas ist was folgt so muss ich
es notwendig auf etwas anderes überhaupt
beziehen was vorher geht und worauf es
nach einer regel das ist
notwendigerweise folgt so dass die
begebenheit als das bedingte auf irgend
eine bedingung sichere anweisungen gibt
diese arbeit die begebenheit bestehen
sie haben das letzte mal darauf
hingewiesen dass sie ganz oft
notwendigkeit vorkommen und das ist
glaube ich dieses zitat am häufigsten
notwendigkeit vorkommen wie kann man das
jetzt verstehen es geht sie als um die
richtung der kausalität kausalität hat
eine richtung
also hier sagt dann dieses zitat wir
können jetzt nicht von der wirkung zur
ursache zurückgehen im sind die
attraktion obwohl natürlich die wirkung
auch zurückweist als wirkung eine
wirkung ist immer die wirkung einer
ursache haben sie noch andere
nur 12
genau
genau das ist nur ein guter punkt den
ich gar nicht so behandelt hatte wenn
jetzt hier die ursache in der kausalen
relation zur b steht dann ist das eine
asymmetrische relation das heißt wenn
die ursache von bs dann erfolgt die
wirkung auf die ursache und das ganze
ist nicht umkehrbar
also ist es nicht denkbar dass eine
ursache auf die wirkung folgt anders ist
es zum beispiel mit verhältnissen wie
identität also wenn etwas mit sich
selbst identisch ist und kann ich das so
oder so drehen haben sie noch andere
beispiele für symmetrische relation wo
ich es umkehren kann also verursachen
[Musik]
was könnte ich genauso gut fühlt sich ja
können sie das auch in so eine logische
relation bringen eine zweistellige
relation zum beispiel oder dass gerade
bildung
[Applaus]
also dann auch identität zb es hat schon
etwas mit sich selbst identisch ist dann
kann ich auch sagen dass dasselbe
natürlich wieder mit sich identisch ist
also wenn ich sage wenn ich jetzt hier
spreche von einer identität ist
identisch
ich mache jetzt mal hier fährt raus dass
die relation steht in der relation der
identität zu b
dann steht auch b in der relation der
identität zu dann kann ich zum drehen
und das geht eben bei kausalität nicht
dass ich das ganze um treten kann
das nennt man eine asymmetrische ja
zudem hat welche jeder zweite diese
begebenheit wird
warum jederzeit ich glaube es geht um
das thema gewissen zeit passiert
und deswegen zu einem anderen zeitpunkt
als anderes notwendig zu jeder zeit
ich verstehe es jetzt ein bisschen
anders
dass alle zu jedem möglichen zeitpunkt
dass es beliebig letztendlich ist wenn
ich es einmal festlegen
dann folgt es zu einem bestimmten
zeitpunkt aber wenn ich es noch offen
lasse wann das die ursache eintritt da
müsste man sagen
durch dieses jederzeit eine
regelmäßigkeit zu bringen ja da ist eine
gute frage ich also lief haben sie ist
noch meldung dazu verschieben müssen
endlich
zu nehmen
ein ganz verschiedene ursachen
das möchte eigentlich kann schon wenn
ich ihnen recht verstehe es kann möchte
im sinne der naturforschung war auch
physiker möchte immer eine ganz
bestimmte ursache haben also für ihn es
ist ganz wichtig dass eine sache
denn sie haben alles aber es geht nicht
zumuten erscheinen zu wollen
zurück blieben
es könnte eben auch empirisch kontingent
ebenso sein dass wir nicht drauf kommen
aber prinzipiell müssen wir darauf
kommen kann aber noch einmal zurück auf
die frage des kommilitonen
wie kann man das jetzt hier verstehen
dass auf nach jederzeit und
notwendigerweise diese begebenheit folgt
jederzeit hier seit ich bei sondern
[Musik]
wählt ihr argument
das problem zu lösen
wird ist momentan das auch etwas anderes
freuen müssen daraus deutlich dass aus
dingen dieser hat nun die meisten dingen
wie nachfolgend das ist einfach jeder
zeit der fußball dann aber wir können
den vielleicht nichts uns vorstellen
dass nicht eine möglichkeit
das ist eben das land
das kernprodukt regelmäßig nach einer
regel gedacht und jetzt sinnlos ganzes
gleich
das ist das problem des regel folgend
dass ich auch bei wittgenstein schon
stellt komme ich da aus diesem zirkel
raus nachdem es von dem sie sprechen
gegeben
anleger die nach der erst am 7 das wäre
nicht leben
genommen das kann man für zwei optionen
an
in zwei anrufen kann dann bedeutet
auch zwei stunden die notwendigkeit wenn
eine notwendigkeit dieser durch hinzu
materialistisches können wir gerne eine
tour gesetz aufstellen weil wie soll das
denn gehen
zudem zeigen wollen was zum nächsten
wir haben
das widerspricht dem computer
ich gebe ich an wendigkeit und kann
zeigt das ist notwendig
ja als wenn wir jetzt aber noch mal von
diesem grundsatz erst mal ausgehen
dieser zweite analogie der erfahrung wie
man analytische zweite analogie darf
dann könnte man das diesen grundsatz
einfach so analysieren das eben wenn
dann b also immer wenn adam b und
vielleicht meint er ebenso jederzeit als
eben immer immer wenn adam
das ist andere fragen wie es begründet
aber jetzt meinem analytischen auf
analytische neben werde es ist eine
spannende frage also ob es typen sind
typen von ereignissen oder vorkommnisse
von ereignissen
das ist jetzt hier erst noch denke ich
offen gelassen
oder wollen sie das
eine allgemeine bedingung nach
diesmal eine faltige mithin auf 13
jahren auf die welt gesetzt werden
die vorstellungen gesetzt habe schritte
auf
ja also mannigfaltigen sind ja dann
immer als synthetische einheit
das ist was synthetisches und etwas wird
ja nur dadurch synthetisch dass ich eben
verstandes begriffe anwenden also wir
bekommen immer eben indem wir von
substanzen sprechen oder mannigfaltiges
synthetisieren bringen wir durch diese
rahmenbedingungen auch immer so ein
bisschen was allgemeines mit rein
zum beispiel dass ich sagen kann dass es
eine substanz wie auch immer die
substanz aussieht dass sie über aber
substanziell verfasst ist das verdankt
dieser diese rahmen hier und die
individualität der substanz gut die
einheit der substanz die verdanke ich
auch diesen rahmenbedingung einheit
vielheit usw ist ein verstandes
kategorie aber ich denke es sollte jetzt
die farbe oder solche dinge die
vielleicht auch die exakte größe
die nämlich müssen aus diesen herkommen
aber man hätte schon ein bisschen dieses
problem gelöst glaube ich dadurch dass
man eben sagt überhaupt eine
individuelle sting zu konstituieren muss
ich schon so ein typ hineinwirken und
den typus ist dann hier diese ist in
diese rahmenbedingung die begrifflich
und dieser tisch aber aber dieser tisch
wäre nur diese tisch weil er eben
insofern ich dieser sagen kann durch die
karte durch die verstandes kategorie der
substanz substantially tt als dieser
überhaupt möglich ist und es heißt in
diesem diesen habe ich immer zugleich
was allgemein ist auch drin
ja das ist also eine spannende frage
also ich stimme da ganz zu dass man da
noch weiter fragen kann also wie es sich
jetzt eben typen arten zu konkreten
individuen dann verhalten und was jetzt
hier und theologisch gesehen jetzt hier
bei dieser qualitäts relation hier
einzusetzen ist das war ja die frage
nach dem motto logischen status der iata
was sind ursachen kann spricht ganz zu
beginn was im netz in der letzten
sitzung gesprochen hat da sprach kann
wenn ich mich nicht täusche von
substanzen sagt substanzen wo sich die
aktie denn ziehen und zwar
interessanterweise kontradiktorisch und
nicht konträr ändern also sagte da ist
ein zustand von dem das gegenteil davor
war versteht es wahrscheinlich so ist
das dauer ist das nicht da also entweder
ja oder nein dann haben wir
kontradiktorische gegensätze mich
konträre es könnte auch sagen rot gelb
blau grün haben wir nicht mehr kontrakte
torischen sachen erscheint kausalität im
sinne des kontradiktorischen also
entweder oder
also dass das nur entgegengesetzten zu
betrachten da sprache von der substanz
die sich die sich eben endet an den sich
akzidenzen ändern das ist für ihn glaube
ich verursachen
also scheint hier substanzen ansätze die
natürlich auch wieder dann ihre formen
bekommen durch die durch die kategorie
der kausalität auf die wir jetzt hier in
diesem text gar nicht eingehen können
natürlich haben zustände der substanz
[Musik]
das ziel ist eine gute punkte den
kommerz auf basis dieser zitate wohl
noch nicht entscheiden und die frage ist
ob man den überhaupt entscheiden kann
also diese frage müssen wir durch aus
oder können sie gerne auch im rahmen
einer hausarbeit mehr nachgehen als wenn
man bei kant genau hinschaut kann man
sich stellen dann findet man wirklich
manchmal problempunkte die ja nicht
nicht klärt also das ist gerade bei
dieser sache der der natur
gesetzlichkeit auch wenn es um freiheit
geht da kann man durchaus sagen kann
sitzt da was voraus was er eigentlich
vielleicht streng genommen gar nicht
zeigen kann also ich finde es vollkommen
berechtigt ihre kritische fragen an kann
zu formulieren und das dann auch
vielleicht gerne hausarbeit noch noch
weiter zu analysieren
also ich finde das sind gute gute
ansatzpunkte
jetzt gehen wir mal weiter er sagt man
setze es geht vor einer begebenheit
nichts vorher worauf die selbe nach
einer regel folgen müsste so wäre alle
folge der wahrnehmung nur lediglich in
der prävention das ist bloss subjektiv
aber dadurch gar nicht objektiv bestimmt
welches eigentlich das vorhergehende und
will jetzt das nachfolgende der
wahrnehmung sein müsste würden auf
solche weise nur ein spiel der
vorstellungen haben dass ich auf gar
kein objekt bezüge das war ihre punkte
korrelation dieses bezug nach außen das
ist es würde durch unsere wahrnehmung
eine erscheinung von jeder anderen dem
zeit verhältnisse nach gar nicht
unterschieden werden weil die sukzession
im april tieren aller werts einer leihe
und also nicht in der erscheinung ist
nichts in der erscheinung ist was sie
bestimmt so dass dadurch eine gewisse
folge als objektiv notwendig gemacht
wird ich werde also nicht sagen dass in
der erscheinung zwei zustände
aufeinanderfolgender nur dass eine
operation auf die andere folgt welches
bloß etwas subjektives ist und kein
objekt bestimmt mit ihm gar nicht für
erkenntnisse irgend eines gegenstandes
selbst nicht in der erfahrung
erscheinung gelten kann
also was will jetzt könnt ihr erreichen
du hast wieder nicht was möchte
ausschließen genau als er möchte nicht
dass die folge der wahrnehmung bloß
subjektiv ist also das ist das problem
sondern sie soll das bekannt dass sie
sie beten sie soll objektiv stimmt sein
man ist ganz klar bestimmt sein was das
vorhergehende das heißt was die ursache
ist und das was die wirkung ist was das
nachfolgend ist also keine beliebigkeit
er ins spiel kommen wenn wir also
erfahren dass etwas geschieht zu setzen
wir aber jeder zeit voraus dass
irgendetwas vorausgehe worauf es nach
einer regel folgt ohne dieses würde ich
nicht von dem objekt sagen dass es folge
weil die bloße folgen einer prävention
wenn sie nicht durch eine regel in
beziehung auf ein vorhergehendes
bestimmt ist keine folge im objekte
berechtigt also geschieht es immer
rücksicht auf eine regel nach welche die
erscheinung in ihrer folgen das ist so
wie sie geschehen
durch den vorherigen zustand bestimmt
sind dass ich meine subjektive synthesis
thema prävention objektiv mache und nur
lediglich unter dieser voraussetzung
allein ist selbst die erfahrung von
etwas was geschieht möglich an sich hier
geht es jetzt wieder um diese regelung
dass regel folge also regel sind ganz
wichtig regeln müssen nachts kann
objektiv sein und er geht so weit dass
selbst sagt erfahrung ist überhaupt nur
möglich wenn sie regelmäßig strukturiert
ist und regeln selbst sind nichts was in
die erfahrung liegt ich kann nicht durch
die erfahrung regeln begründen
das wollte david hume an ich kann nur
erfahrung haben durch regeln also die
regeln wird nicht aus der erfahrung
entnommen sozusagen durch induktion gibt
es so induktions schlüssel
also wir haben jetzt hier 20.000 halde
selbe ereignis gehabt den adern b und
daraus folgen wir dass es eine regel ist
also stabil ist stabilität
[Musik]
abhängigkeiten feste beziehung können
wir aus der erfahrung streng genommen
nicht objektiv begründers erkannt sagt
er auch schon dem medium sondern
entweder wir müssen uns auf so einen
relativistischen standpunkt begeben wie
der mit junges tun sagen wir können
immer nur relative aussagen treffen will
kann sagen mit einer gewissen
wahrscheinlichkeit es war so häufig in
der vergangenheit und jetzt sind wir
dadurch berechtigt das wird die zukunft
und für den gegebenen fall auch
anzunehmen induktions schluss also wir
haben es jetzt eben müssten dann sagen
von fall zu fall verschieden einmal wenn
man es tausendmal beobachtet hat für
unsere lebenswelt würde ist vielleicht
genug mit zehn mal können sie sich
selbst fragen wie häufig muss ein
ereignis oder müssen zwei ereignisse in
einer bestimmten abfolge in ihrer
erfahrung aufgetreten sein damit sie
sagen würden das ist eine regel daran
halte ich mich jetzt möchte ich gleich
sind sie dann in der umfrage noch machen
also wie häufig über die überlegen sie
mal ganz kurz
ab wann würden sie in ihren
lebensweltlichen kontext im alter davon
ausgehen dass was auch wenn nur
subjektive regelhaftigkeit hat wie
häufig müssten sie die selben ereignisse
gemacht haben nach derselben ordnung
immer gnade
dass sie diesen schluss für ihren
lebensweg im kontext zimpel
warum kann man natürlich keine zahlen
machen und kosten machen machen sie noch
gegen den sack aber für mich genau zum
beispiel also ich gebe mal beispiele sie
hat ein beispiel noch her
ok
okay sie wird also in den relationen
dann denken okay
also zum beispiel ist ich gehe mal ein
beispiel wenn ich zum beispiel häufig
beim bahnfahren fällt mir das häufig auf
bin ich eben jetzt morgens von garching
kommen häufig die erfahrung gemacht habe
in einer gewissen regelmäßigkeit zum
beispiel dreimal hintereinander viermal
hintereinander war die bahn verspätet
dann werde ich schon beim dritten
vierten mal das geht ganz schnell
vermutlich das ist einfach subjektiv
psychologisch ist genügt für mädchen
manchen es hängt natürlich vom kontext
ab aber wenn es zum beispiel
morgendlichen staus sind oder oder
unfälle oder sonstige verzögerungen da
reagiert man sehr empfindlich als einen
sehr ärgert man muss natürlich immer
noch frau sitzen ist es jetzt für ein
wichtig oder nicht und in solchen fällen
genügt es also lebensweltlich
psychologisch bei den allermeisten
menschen dass das 34 mal dass da drei
vier mal eine gewisse regelmäßigkeit
folgt sogar manchmal nur zweimal war ich
zu behaupten und schon erstmal in der
disposition
dass man es für das nächste mal selben
uhrzeit auch vermutet und dann kann man
zum beispiel schließen ja irgendwie das
bahnsystem der münchner u-bahn ist nach
oben also beim volk gleich zum schluss
wir können lebens wirklich gar nicht
anders denken als immer generalisierende
schlüsse zu ziehen die häufigen
natürlich falsch sind in allermeisten
fällen sind die falsch und werden wir
fallen zitiert werden wir wieder legt
und dann bilden wir neue hypothese das
geschieht also behaupte ich jetzt mal in
unserem lebensweltlichen kontext viel
häufiger als es die physiker machen die
eben nicht alle als halbe jahr ihre groß
theorien über den haufen werfen sondern
das sind die großzügigen stabiler aber
meine these wer aus evolutionären
gründen psychologische tiefe oder andere
besteht aus evolutionären gründen sind
wir so getrimmt dass in manchen
situationen zwei bis dreimalige
vorkommen der ereignisse derselben art
wenn sie uns betreffen
dass die uns in eine situation versetzen
dass wir geneigt sind
das können ganz wenige vorkommens sein
wir sind total disponiert dazu regeln zu
induzieren induktiv zu erschließen wenn
wir nur ganz wenig anhaltspunkte dazu
haben
ich glaube dass so auch nur unsere unser
revolutionäres er überleben erklärt
werden kann ja nicht noch nicht
einstellen wenn das handy kann ist wenn
es einmal endlich da helfen nur siege
einfahren würde ich ja nur einer woche
haben eine einzige delegierte
[Musik]
das wäre jetzt ein argument was nicht
nur wer das psychologisch nein sie würde
sagen es liegt der notwendigkeit des
endlichen wesens sich also gar keine
psychologische aussage würden sie sagen
einfach das endliche wesen angesichts
seiner möglichen erfahrung
ich möchte indem sie das sagen dass es
so handeln muss sind sich schon fast auf
einen transall- philosophischen
standpunkt wie kantinen bezieht also
jung würde sagen das ist alles ein
empirischer man könnte jetzt sagen aus
der logischen struktur des endlichen
wesens können wir vielleicht noch
irgendwas reduzieren ok also spannende
punkt
ich habe ein bisschen weiter
jetzt kommt vielleicht noch was
interessant ist wird die diskussion
davor das ist ein bisschen weiter dass
es b 244 mbs immer die kritik der reinen
vernunft diebe zweite auflage von 1787
in der synthesis als ihm zusammensetzen
der erscheinung folgt das mannigfaltige
der vorstellung dieser zeit nacheinander
hierdurch wird nun gar kein objekt
vorgestellt weil durch diese folge diana
prävention gemein ist nichts von anderen
unterschieden
sobald ich aber wahrnehmen oder voraus
annehmen dass dieser folge eine
beziehung auf den vorherigen vergebenen
zustand sei aus welchem die vorstellung
nach einer regel folgt zu stellt sich
etwas vor als begebenheit oder was da
geschieht das ist ich erkenne einen
gegenstand den ich ihnen derzeit auf
eine gewisse bestimmte stelle setzen
muss die ihm nach dem vorhergehenden
zustande nicht anders erteilt werden
kann
wenn ich also wahrnehmen dass etwas
geschieht so ist in dieser vorstellung
ärztlich enthalten das etwas vorher gehe
weil eben in beziehung auf dieses die
erscheinung ihr zeit verhältnis bekommt
nämlich nach einer vorhergehenden zeit
in der sie nicht wahr zu existieren aber
ihre bestimmte zeit stellen diesen
verhältnissen kann sie nun dadurch
bekommen dass im vorhergehenden zustand
etwas vorausgesetzt wird worauf es
jederzeit jetzt haben wir es noch mal
hier jederzeit das ist nach einer regel
folgt
ja
immer wenn adam b also konditionell
konditionen
und jetzt kann man sich fragen ist das
überzeugend das ist der weitere punkte
die frage war es aber nur nach der
bedeutung von jederzeit und hier ist das
ist das ist also hier äquivalente
aber ob das überzeugend ist das ist dann
noch eine andere frage da haben sie es
sicherlich recht aber wenn sie jetzt nur
fragen nach der bedeutung von jederzeit
hätte man hier so eine antwort darauf ob
das jetzt von der logik her der türken
ob jetzt als war es jetzt aufeinander
folgen jetzt tücken von ereignissen
aufeinanderfolgen nur konkrete
vorkommnisse aufeinander was sind die
identitäten dieser rat sind das tippen
oder sind es sind sicherlich natürlich
ganz konkrete ereignisse aber wie können
wir diese ganz konkreten ereignisse dann
noch typisieren
das ist dann die frage der
suchfunktionen als wir subsumieren eben
immer konkretes gegebenes in der
synthesis unter ein allgemeines und ich
vermute jetzt mal obwohl es könnte nicht
sagt dass wir eben die verbindlichkeit
der erkenntnisse dadurch bekommt dass
wir alle mannigfaltigen erfahrungen eben
immer auf diese generellen kategorien
beziehen und das dadurch durch diese
rahmung dass dadurch eben diese im
verhältnis setzung möglich wird von
ursachen wirkungen aber es ist ein
riesenthema also ein riesenfass also es
ist kann man ganze seminar über machen
kannst wahrnehmung story lesen oder
wollten sie noch was zu sagen oder soll
ich weiter lesen
sie benutzt und weiß genau dass er mal
ein fehler ist also zu jeder zeit ist
nach einer regel ja auch sagen die wege
ist es mit dem 34
das macht wäre die regel ist alle zeit
gültig aber betrifft also partie
wenn man so ein bisschen zeit von kurz
kommen
neben den regeln und
was die bedeutung die der redaktion
die bedingungen die das eintreffen des
konsequenten
recht
[Musik]
das hatten sie sich gerade gemeldet
das ist theoretisch ist denkbar dass das
ist immer so dass am 28 november das
war's egal wie man denkt aber in seiner
decke ist vielleicht zeigt ja nicht
irgendwelche erstmal und dann also nicht
erstellt das ist eine hypothetische zeit
es wäre uns das kind sei das um die zeit
bereit sind in der regel keine zeit
vielleicht weil ihm zusammen die sich
auch etwas positives ziehen oder auch
etwas
so oder so
also ich kann sagen dass diese regeln
und position
das ist so sehr gut an diese zeit und
aufwand also das ist doch legitim regel
seien diese für dich nicht nur für das
schon witzig sein
über das projekt das bringt etwas
jederzeit offen
zu recht
wir lesen vielleicht mal kurz noch
weiter weil er jetzt hier noch ein
bisschen noch eine nähere bestimmung
gibt er sagt woraus sich den ergibt sagt
er hier
woraus sich denn ergibt dass sich
ärztlich nicht die reihe umkehren das
ist also die asymmetrische relation und
das was geschieht demjenigen vor
ansetzen kann worauf es folgt zweitens
dass wenn der zustand der vorher geht
also die ursache gesetzt wird diese
bestimmte begebenheit die wirkung
ausbleibt und notwendig folge als sie
haben jetzt einmal die notwendigkeit ist
auch ganz wichtig dadurch geschieht ist
das eine ordnung unter unseren
vorstellungen wird die welche das
gegenwärtige sofern es geworden auf
irgendein vorhergehenden zustand
anweisung gibt also zur rücksicht
bezieht als ein ob zwar noch
unbestimmtes korrelat um dieses
ereignisses das gegeben ist welches sich
aber auf dieses als seine folge
bestimmen bezieht und sie notwendig mit
sich in der zeit drei verknüpft also
hier ist ganz wichtig dieses verknüpfen
verknüpfen dass es wieder die synthese
synthetische und diese synthetischen
leistung das sind alles diese rahmen
leistung das letzte die letzte instanz
die diese ganzen dinge zusammen bringt
als interessiert das habe ich jetzt noch
gar nicht hier eingetragen was müsste
ich den wir jetzt noch machen was ist
der höchste rahmen der letzte rahmen den
ich hier noch um zeichen muss wissen sie
es überlegen sie mal was ist der grund
nach kant das setzt jetzt ein bisschen
weiteres wissen voraus dass ich diese
ganzen einheits bildung diese ganzen
verknüpfungen leisten kann das ist also
dieses daten hier mit kausalität
substanz und so weiter verknüpfen was
das einheits zentrum
genau das ist dass ich das trans
zentrale ich das sagt er jetzt in diesem
text nicht aber das ist transzendentale
ich dass ich das muss alle meine
vorstellungen und begleiten können als
wir haben es hier eine vorstellung hier
eine vorstellung hier haben jetzt
kausalität erfahrung hier und hier
aber was gibt dem ganzen seine letzte
einheit das ist nach kann das trans
zentrale ich dass ich und dass ich es
jetzt nicht psychologisch zu verstehen
sondern eben als bedingung als höchste
bedingung der möglichkeit als letzte
aufhänge punkt da ist alles aufgehängt
zuletzt die einheits punkte aussetzen
als äußerst waren zwei verschiedene
gut das ist ein guter punkt
ja das ist ein guter punkt also wir
haben jetzt hier da könnte jetzt noch
sehr viel weiter drüber reden aber wir
haben jetzt noch 1500 zeit und ich würde
sagen jetzt gehen wir auf ihre frage ein
bisschen noch näher ein
die frage die sie jetzt gestellt haben
nach der koordination an wissen alles
koordinierungs leistungen deckt die
koordination von kausalität der natur
die ja wie gesagt das müssen sich immer
vorstellen nach kann die kausalität der
natur hier ist nichts was von außen
kommt was außerhalb von uns
transzendentale gedacht jetzt liegt sind
die kausalität der natur
die verdankt sich unserem rahmen der
kausalität das ist als die kausalität
der natur ist dieser rahmen texten
unserem trans and arlen ich der ist
nicht draußen das ist was inneren alles
innere aber transzendentale innere
logisch inneren nicht empirisch in
sachen jetzt stellt sich die frage wie
hängt denn jetzt wieder schön
diese haben hier mit dieser sache hier
der kausalität aus freiheit zusammen
die ja auch in uns ist und jetzt merken
es hier wird es plötzlich ganz
kompliziert jetzt gibt es hier noch
weitere faktoren weitere arten von
kausalität das ist die akteurs
kausalität ich kann anderen hinschreiben
akteurs
halle die tatsache dass wir nicht nur
den naturgesetz unterliegen oder dass
wir naturbeobachtung machen als wenn wir
naturbeobachtung machen machen wir nach
kant eigentlich selbstbeobachtung tanz
zentrale selbstbeobachtung nämlich
verhältnisse die nach unserer kategorie
bekam sieht sich ereignet gut
eingestanden zugegeben wir haben noch
die säckchen die da eine rolle spielen
diese x10 hier die spielen wenn es jetzt
um die kausalität aus freiheit geht gar
keine rolle
das ist der schlüssel wenn es um die die
haushalte aus freiheit geht bleiben wir
rein bei uns sozusagen da hat
wahrnehmung spielt er gar keine rolle da
synthetisieren wir etwas da bringen wir
etwas hervor was nicht empirisch ist auf
keine weise mit anschauung zu tun hat da
sind wir an einem punkt könnte man sagen
wo seine art von intellektuell arche
typus den kann eigentlich ausgeschlossen
hat für endlich gewesen wo so ein
intellektueller youtube ist er etwas
selbst hervorbringen kann ohne auf
anschauung angewiesen zu sein
die sächsischen möglich ist und das ist
nach kant die frei handeln frei handlung
ist etwas hervor gebrachtes was ich
nicht solche nixon verdanken dass keine
anschauen darf und das muss jetzt aber
wieder mit dieser natur kausalität
zusammenstimmen weil das was wir hier
tun ist natürlich aus dem gesichtspunkt
eines physikers vollkommen determiniert
also es kann ganz gut er kann sagt alles
was wir tun alles was wir aus freiheit
tun kann ist der größte gefühl wurde
gefeiert
alles was wir uns vorher tun ist
zugleich vollständig durch das
naturgesetz determiniert aber dennoch
ist unsere handlung frei obwohl sie
total determiniert ist das heißt kann
ist auf eine gewisse weise 1 kompatibel
ist von natur und freiheit aber auf eine
gewisse weise auch nicht kompatibel ist
weil er nämlich beide gesetze nun
eingeschränkt gelten lässt und häufig
ist ein kompatibel ist muss so zu
vertreten dass einer dieser prinzipien
ein bisschen modifiziert und kanten
keinerlei modifikationen an diesen zwei
arten von freiheit oder determination
vor und der schlüssel zu diesem dieser
frage jetzt nach dem verhältnis von 1000
aus freiheit und kann sich jetzt aus
natur der league geben auch in der
kritik der reinen vernunft derselben
schrift aus der wir die zweite analogie
die erfahrung heute das letzte mal
behandelt hatten aber in der so
genannten dritten antinori die dritte
antinori betrifft die frage wie sich
qualität der natur und kausalität aus
freiheit verhalten also die an tino
mewes fraktion hat widerspruch in
unserer vernunft wir werden genötigt
durch unsere vernunft erkannt anzunehmen
dass alles was existiert dem naturgesetz
unterlegt wir werden aber auch genötigt
durch die vernunft dass wir frei sind
und dass wir frei sind scheint der
tatsache zu widersprechen dass alle
unsere ereignisse auf dem naturgesetz
gründung dass sie dadurch einfluss zum
kanzler es lässt sich tatsächlich
vereinbaren und jetzt lesen wir dass
noch ein bisschen weiter er sagte das
ist eine these also sagt die kausalität
nach gesetzen der natur
die ursache ist nicht die einzige aus
welche die erscheinung der welt
insgesamt abgeleitet werden können es
ist noch eine kausalität durch freiheit
aus wahrheit zur erklärung derselben
anzunehmen notwendig und jetzt versuchte
das zu beweisen
man nehme an es gebe keine andere kaufen
als bekannt macht jetzt ein 1 1
eine art von indirekten beweis dass es
eine 1 ab agrogeschäft beweis oder auch
eine reduktion absurdum
also es gibt entweder a oder b er will
beweisen oder zeigt dass nicht b und
daraus folgt dann als er sagt ist nur
wir nehmen alles wäre nicht so das ist
nicht gut
und daraus folgt jetzt wille zur letzten
widerspruch volk also man eben alles
gebe keine andere alte sanität als nach
gesetzen der natur so setzt alles was
geschieht ein vorigen zustand voraus auf
den espoirs bleibt nach einer regel
folgt nun muss aber der vorstand selbst
etwas zeigen was geschehen ist in der
zeit geworden da es nicht vorher nicht
fahren weil wenn es jeder zeit gewesen
wie er seine folge auch nicht aller erst
entstanden seien immer gewesen sein
würde
also ist die kausalität der ursache
durch will ich etwas geschieht selbst
etwas geschehen ist welches nach dem
gesetze der natur wiederum einen vorigen
zustand und dessen kausalität diese aber
ebenso in einem noch älteren voraussetzt
und so weiter geht immer weiter zurück
liegende ursache
wenn also alles nach dem bloßen gesetzen
der natur geschieht so gibt es jederzeit
nur einen subalternen also
untergeordneten niemals ab einen
relativen untergeordneten niemals aber
ein erster anfang und also überhaupt
keine vollständigkeit der reihe auf der
seite der voneinander ab standen
ursachen nun besteht aber eben darin das
gesetz der natur das ohne hinreichend
apriori bestimmte ursache nichts
geschehen also widerspricht der satz als
wenn alle kausalität nur nach
naturgesetzen möglich sei sich selbst in
seiner unbeschränkten allgemeinheit und
diese kann also nicht als die einzige
angenommen werden
das ist jetzt die rettung zu absurd um
die sind nach muss eine kausalität
angenommen werden durch wäre etwas
geschieht ohne dass die ursache davon
noch weiter durch eine andere
vorhergehende ursache nach notwendigen
gesetze bestimmt sein
das ist eine absolute spontaneität
ursachen eine reifen erscheinung in der
natur besitzen läuft von selbst
anzufangen mithin trans zentrale
freiheit ohne welche selbst hat man
selbst im laufe der natur die
reihenfolge der erscheinung auf das
seite der ursachen niemals vollständig
ist also das was er jetzt hier
transzendentale freiheit nimmt oder auch
die absolute spontanität der ursachen
hier
das ist gerade das hier es gibt hier
absoluten anfangen und es ist nicht
normal weiter vor sein
und das sagt kant ist jetzt irgendwie
notwendig anzusetzen können sie noch
einmal kurz zurück nachverfolgen mal
wiederholen warum sagt gibt es kann
genügt es nicht nur sowas wie natur
qualität anziehen was das problem wenn
wir davon ausgehen dass alles was
geschieht eine ursache hat und zwar bis
ins unendliche weiter was erlangen wir
danach nicht demnach nicht mehr kann
hier sagt das
jawohl
genau also wenn es immer nur immer nur
einen vorgänger gibt dann haben wir nie
das ganze das absolute leuchtet ein
das heißt den vorschlägen
ja
absoluten anfangen vielleicht also es
geht er sucht praktisch den begriff der
absoluten ursachen als wenn ich ein
recht verstehen was sie warnt auch noch
dann kann man nach diesem verständnis
nur von relativen ursachen sprechen weil
ja eigentlich jeder ursache nach diesem
verständnis auch eine wirkung ist und
dann kann man eigentlich nie richtig
sagen was ist jetzt möglich eine ursache
gewesen sondern jede ursache ist aus
einem anderen gesichtspunkt vom
vorherigen gesehen
ich kann immer subalterne ich kann immer
zurück gehen also wenn ich jetzt sage
hier dass sie ist jetzt eine ursache
dann gehe ich hier hin und hab mir dann
nur praktisch null dass wir dann zur u1
und u2 ist die wirkung von 0 und also
ich habe nie den den absoluten ursache
gefährden
das scheint
wir brauchen zuwendung mit welchem punkt
als kostet der anspruch des romans
absolut unsere deutschen besatzung
also das ist ja nicht
das ist scheiße
und für mich ist eigentlich
mit dem bus sind
fr
die bestand
grund
genau
genau das war das beste
anzug zu sagen dass auch die farben
genausogut der hinweis dass jetzt auf
die zwei vermögen oder zwei formen der
versprechen kommen kann unterscheidet
zwischen verstand und vernunft der
verstand ist jetzt das nach kant das
immer hier von jedem ereignis immer
wieder mit weiteren ursache finden das
ist sozusagen die instrumentelle
vernunft konnte massa was war die
ursache davon was war die ursache davon
der verstand nach kant denkt immer von
jedem den grund ursache zuvor und kommt
zur bis ins unendliche findet nie eine
ruhe ist der verstand und die vernunft
nach kant die denkt eben das absolut die
vernunft ist in uns so angelegt dass sie
sie will den erst und die erste ursache
denken das heißt wir müssen jetzt in
diese rahmung hier noch den verstand und
die vernunft noch einzeichnen ja
gewissermaßen ich mache jetzt mal so ich
mache jetzt mal jetzt ganz schwierig
weil also der verstand wird konstituiert
durch diese diese kategorien raum nicht
durch substanz kausalität und andere
sachen also das habe ich jetzt nicht
genau gezeigt als wir meinen verstand
einzeichnen wollen müssen wir jetzt
praktisch hier doch meine rahmen unter
allen träumen
die über substanz und qualität machen
das ist der verstand der verstand also
pause tate im sinne der natur und
sachlichkeit und jetzt gibt es eben auch
noch die vernunft ist jetzt ganz
schlicht die ein zeichen und die denkt
eben nicht so dass es immer wieder eine
ursache findet was gibt es an die
vernunft denkt was war der erst anfangen
was man die erste absolute ursache
völlig richtig genau das ist also das
ist genau die platonische unterscheidung
von news das ist die vernunft auch
etymologisch damit verwandt die stellt
die frage nach dem ersten und letzten
auch was das ende woher kommen wir wohin
gehen wir dass die prüft und die diana
hat das ist die die rechnende sage ich
jetzt mal die rechnende vernunft eben
immer wieder ursachen von ereignissen
angeben kann
und diese zwei manchmal dimensionen
unserer rationalität die sind nach kann
letztendlich dafür zuständig dass wir
hier einmal für natur und einmal von
freiheit reden und wir können das ist
nur die perspektive der auflösung wir
können beides dadurch vereinbaren indem
wir eben sagen die kausalität ära touren
die causa freiheit sind dimension oder
ausprägung unseres vernunft vermögens
wir haben eben den verstand in uns der
gibt tätig einheit der natur und die
natur ursachen und die ganze unendliche
reihe und wir haben die vernunft im
engeren sinne die nach dem ersten
letzten frage
und die ist die ursache für unsere
freiheit und da eben wir selbst als
zentrales objekte sowohl vernünftige
momente als auch verständigen momenten
uns haben können wir eben durch unsere
rationalität struktur
beide formen von ursächlichkeit die
absolute ursächlichkeit wie auch die
relative ursächlichkeit miteinander in
der einheit bringen also dass die
einheit dieser beiden formen der gesetze
ist fundiert in der einheit unseres
verstandes
jetzt leben sie noch ein letztes zitat
müssen schluss machen wir kommen dem
nächsten sitzung noch ganz kurz darauf
zurück da machen wir glaube ich
schopenhauer
die über die vierfache wurzel das war
der wunsch eines kommilitonen ich
schicke es da noch rum also letztes
zitat die trans zentrale idee der
freiheit macht zwar bei weitem nicht den
ganzen inhalt des psychologischen
begriffs dieses namens aus welcher
großenteils empirisch ist sie nur dem
der absolut spontan absoluten
spontanität der handlung als den
eigentlichen grund der input agilität
ist die zurechenbarkeit desselben ist
aber dennoch der eigentliche stein des
anstoßes für die philosophie welche
unüberwindlichen schwierigkeiten findet
der gleichen art von unbedingter
kausalität das ist die das ist praktisch
dass wir keine weiteren ursachen
einzuräumen der dasjenige alte in der
frage über die freiheit des willens was
die spekulative vernunft von jeher in so
große verlegenheit gesetzt hat ist
eigentlich nur transzendentale und geht
lediglich darauf ob ein vermögen
angekommen werden müsse eine reihe von
sukzessiven dingen oder zuständen von
selbst anzufangen absolut anfangen wie
ein solches möglich sein ist nicht
ebenso notwendige beantworten zu können
da wir uns eben sowohl bei der
kausalität nach naturgesetzen damit
begnügen müssen apriori zu erkennen dass
eine solche vorausgesetzt werden müsse
ob ihr gleich die möglichkeit wie durch
ein gewisses dasein das dasein eines
anderen gesetzt werde auf keine weise
begreifen und des falls lediglich an die
erfahrung halten müssen da haben wir
diese notwendigkeit eines ersten anfangs
einer reifen erscheinung aus freiheit
zwar nur eigentlich insofern da getan
als zur begrifflichkeit eines ursprungs
der wild erforderlich ist indessen man
alle nachfolgenden zustände für eine
abfolge nach bloßen gesetzen nehmen kann
als man bis dahin ist kant nennt diese
form der freiheit die also ein erster
absoluter anfang ist transzendentale
freiheit und die gründet in der
vernünftige engeren sinne wie die
kommilitonen richtig sagt während der
naturgesetze dass der die naturgesetze
im verstand
das ist also eine andere dimension
unserer nationalität begründet ist in
der nächsten sitzung die finden die
folien alle auch viel lob ist unter
diesen reiter folien da finden sie die
folien
schauen sie doch mal anders sind ich mir
viele nur noch vier folien werden wir
noch mal kurz darauf zurückgehen nochmal
das verhältnis von freiheits kausalität
und vernunft und natur kausalität klären
und dann gehen wir über auf schopenhauer
und auf seine dissertation über die
vierfache wurzel des zu reichen grundes
dann schicke ich ihnen auch noch ein
paar sachen herum das war noch der
wunsch eines kommilitonen und dann mit
dem ende von schopenhauers schrift
werden wir in der zweiten hälfte des
semesters auf die aktuellen debatten der
kausalität eingehen
die überwiegend angelsächsischer
provinzen jens sind das heißt wir
verlassen kontinentaleuropa und gehen
nach england oder die usa